I dated a girl,
worked at uh,
Newport cream.
Are you with me?
Okay.
What's that like a like a cold stone ice cream place.
Hamburgers?
Yeah.
Who's that?
You remember me?
That's me.
This fucking phone.
I've uh,
got a phone that for whatever reason turns itself on to ring all the time.
Yeah.
Like even when I don't,
it turns the cell phone to ring.
It's done that like
twice.
You know what?
I think it's this case,
this leather apple case.
I think it's a piece of shit.
Look at your volume buttons.
Look at mine.
They're sunk in the middle.
Like this suddenly had this like,
uh,
for a week and it's already falling apart.
None of it and not join in it overheats your phone.
I think because of the leather.
There's no way for the air to get out so that my shit's running slower than it
should.
You don't have to do the other day I put a battery pack on this like a madman.
Yeah.
Pulling them thick ass battery packs on it.
It felt like a superhero.
I could just go all day.
Why don't you have it on now?
Because I took it off because I feel like I was relying on it too much.
I should just charge it at night.
I'm using my,
my phone less and less after my trip to Hawaii because my phone broke.
I dropped it the first day there and I had an order,
a new one,
but I mean,
mine just stop working.
The whole thing.
Yeah.
Duty would just randomly call people.
I would hold up,
I would hold up like my,
uh,
contacts and it would just start calling people and then I would hang up and it
would start calling another person.
No,
hang up.
It was dark and I was showing people,
it's like my friend John Duffy.
I was like,
watch this,
watch what it's doing.
And then I'd hang up.
It would do that again.
It was like,
what the fuck?
I just dropped it and just went haywire.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I broke it.
And so,
uh,
what I'm,
when I got a new one for three days,
I wasn't doing anything.
So for three days waiting for my phone to come,
I didn't use any APPS,
any nothing.
And I felt better.
I felt better.
But you were in Hawaii?
Yeah.
If you were in Van Nuys,
but as soon as I got the phone back then like,
hmm,
let me check Instagram.
Anybody put any cool pictures of cars up there?
If technology is so fragile and like that,
then why are we still so scared of like AI?
If we could just fund it,
smack it,
and the bread's a silly way to look at nuclear bombs.
Jamie,
that's technology to remember.
I know I said it was silly.
I started off by saying smoke
too much.
Do Do da or not enough?
Mm hmm.
Hmm.
We should be worried.
Don't you think if Elon Musk thinks we should be worried?
I A,
he's like in the business of that though of worrying people.
No,
no,
but I mean of technology.
He,
yeah.
Well also,
Yeah,
100% no,
not 100% but like that's his business.
35% future of all technology.
He's,
he's the one figuring out the problems.
He's the one here to save us from all of this shit.
That's his business.
As He created
all those Tesla's got recalled.
I mean did you saw that right?
Like 130,000 model s has got recalled cause they're steering column was fucked
up or something.
Is that what happened?
I don't know exact problem but a lot of them cause I remember
seeing something.
How crazy is it?
Ford canceled all their cars.
Ryan Callan loves his,
he fucking loves it.
Yeah.
Ford decided to stop making cars except the motherfucking Mustang and SUV is I
think,
well the SUV is are awesome.
They make that Lincoln town.
What does it not?
I'm good.
Why did they make it Lincoln navigator?
There's new navigator.
It's a fucking incredible car.
It's incredible.
It's like they saw all these other cars like you know that luxury SUV family
wagon market is a weird market.
Like there's range rovers and there's a bunch of Mercedes SUV is and BMW SUV is.
But this is like the first other than the Cadillac Escalade kind of.
But this was like another level like super high tech family luxury sled that
hauls ass.
It's pretty dope.
Dude.
I watched some of the videos on it and how they make these things and like all
the different features that they have in them.
Huge screens now.
Everything has giant screens.
Like a lot of these cars now,
they don't have a dashboard.
They just have a screen and you know you could just,
you could customize it in different ways.
In my mind is a fake screen or scowling [inaudible] screen virtual virtual
gauges,
right?
Yeah.
It comes on and sub rainieri man.
It's crazy.
It's weird.
It's weird to see.
I got a video.
We should watch this coming up from the Google io thing.
It might counter contradict what we were just,
it says,
no joke.
Google assistant will start making phone calls to small businesses to make
appointments on your behalf.
It's called Google duplex.
The API call or even ads?
Oms and EMS.
Oh Jesus.
Hi.
I'm calling about the woman haircut.
I'm looking at becoming a maker.
It's not a real voice.
We do not have,
if
you have anything that Pete can am and 12:00 PM
she would buy
hair cut for now.
Okay.
You have the
headache.
Okay.
We're here.
The first thing that we thought.
Okay,
perfect.
So I will be lead by 10 o'clock on May 3rd okay,
great.
Great.
Have a great day.
That's awesome.
I love that.
All right,
cool.
You're freaking me out.